aquí tenemos la parte positiva de la
gráfica de igual a 1 entre x y lo que
nos interesa es calcular el área el área
bajo la curva de arriba del eje x entre
x igual a 1 e infinito nos interesa
entonces calcular el área de esta región
para calcular el área establecemos
entonces la integral impropia la
integral desde uno hasta infinito de la
función de uno entre x de x y de nueva
cuenta esto va a ser igual al límite
déjame ponerlo mejor con el mismo color
amarillo
esto va a ser igual al límite cuando n
tiene infinito del integral de 1 a n de
1 / x de x y esto va a ser igual a
límite cuando n tiene infinito obtengo
la anti derivada de una entre x que es
el logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de x entonces va a ser igual al límite
cuando entiende infinito del logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de x aunque
este valor absoluto no afecta mucho
estamos evaluando desde x igual a uno
hasta infinito pero bueno vamos a
incluirlo
esto es entonces el logaritmo natural
del valor absoluto de x evaluado de 1 a
n y esto va a ser igual al límite cuando
n tiende a infinito de logaritmos
natural del valor absoluto de n
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
n pero en es positivo en es mayor que 1
así es que esto es simplemente el
logaritmo natural de n menos gobierno
actual del valor absoluto de 1 que
simplemente logaritmo natural de 1
gobierno actual de 1 es cero y al acero
es igual a 1 y que nos resulta aquí esto
va a ser igual al límite
cuando n tiene infinito de logaritmo
natural de n iv que pasa aquí
bueno la función logaritmo natural
siempre está creciendo va aumentando su
valor conforme x aumenta tiene la
siguiente forma para valores grandes de
x crece un ritmo más lento pero siempre
sigue creciendo por lo que el límite
cuando n tiende infinito del logaritmo
natural de n va a ser igual a infinito
lo cual quiere decir que aquí no tenemos
un área finita esta es un área infinita
una área infinita y esto es interesante
cuando esto se crecía más rápido cuando
la función era 1 / x cuadrada el área la
finita pero ahora hemos encontrado un
área infinita y por eso diremos que esta
integral esta integral impropia es
divergente divergente y con esto hemos
terminado